I was doing a movie in New York and
we're shooting in the Bronx but I mean
like they're really in the projects in
the Bronx yeah and and they did not want
us there
because we were interfering with the
drug trade and whatever else was going
on there and so we had to wear hard hats
to the set because they'd be throwing
[__] off the out of the windows you know
all those big high-rise building there
and throw them out of the window and
he'd be ducking stuff you know that they
weren't happy to have you there so we
had to get some some
some guy with a gang leader to go in and
negotiate with them to like not do it
while we were shooting and anyway it was
when you started smoking again there no
it wasn't that so much it was
um it was a small budget and it was
really a uh a tough schedule
and
maybe one
I've done so much stuff I think I've
only ever had
issues with the director three times
maybe and this was one time and it was a
big one it was what the issue the issue
a little bit we were just
okay this is what happened
here's when you know I was I was doing
this it was with Viola Davis
and um before she was you know Viola
she's massive now yeah and I'm so happy
for her because she's one of the nicest
women I ever worked with in my life
anyway we're doing this movie and it was
pretty low budge and
um I was doing a scene
uh with Viola
and the director
keeps the same would stop when it's like
oh can you do it um you can do it again
and I'll be like sure what do you want
because I'm pretty much like that I
don't mind I love directions yeah money
but he wouldn't he wouldn't say
specifically what he wanted just do it
again just do it again and I thought
well it might be a bit different this
time
so I do it again and this this happened
about four times
and then uh
I said to him I listen I mean you got to
be more specific I keep doing it and I I
don't know what you want and he was very
frustrated and he said I I just want you
to do it the way to
oh boy the way the guy that did the
auditions
did it in the auditions you mean the guy
who reads I read it yeah the reader the
reader yeah this is what he says to an
establishment he was very frustrated and
this is what he said it came out look I
could see it flying you know like
something's flying out of people's
mouths and they're desperately try to
get him back are you a mind reader first
of all no nobody that came out of his
mouth and I and I said to him well look
we're about a weekend you can always get
him
get him and he can do it you know if he
was reading the lights better than me
then I suggest you get him I don't want
to screw up your movie I don't get upset
by stuff like that so I just suggested
he get the other guy and uh and they
kind of went downhill from there
and uh I know
Hayden Panettiere was in it
that's a good joke what's it called do
you remember not saying that's all right
that's a while back no let me ask you
this